[Musique]
on va plus loin mais comme chaque
mercredi parmi nous ya d'imams directeur
du mensuel voire gazzin bronze yade face
à vous bruno daroux de la rédaction de
france 24 bonjour brunoh bonjour à faire
et c'est un procès qui fera date à n'en
pas douter deux mois et demi après le
meurtre d'un homme de 62 ans un civil
dans le nord-est de l'ukraine le soldats
russes soupçonnés de l'avoir abattu et
déjà jugés à kiev pour violation du
droit de la guerre et assassinats il n'a
d'ailleurs pas caché sa responsabilité
écouter
savez vous de quoi vous êtes accusé oui
est-ce que vous plaidez coupable oui je
plaide coupable pour toutes les charges
vous accepté de témoigner oui je vais
témoigner
à l'origine un banal vol de voiture par
des soldats russes pensent en avoir été
aperçus par un bateau il décide de
l'éliminer pour éviter qu'ils le délai
dénonce un crime qu'aurait donc exécuter
cet homme que vous venez de voir le
sergent vadim chichi marine arrêté par
la suite par l'armée ukrainienne il a
dit lors de sa déposition avoir abattu
le témoin gênant sur ordre d'un de ses
compagnons d'armes selon la loi
ukrainienne il encourt la prison à
perpétuité bruno daroux on efface un
seul à ordinaire qui assume un sang
véritablement d'ailleurs donné
d'explication un crime qu on pourrait
presque qualifier de droit commun loin
de l'image du génocidaire endoctrinés
oui absolument
ce gars est un jeune soldat russe fille
laïla 21 ans qui s'est trouvé
effectivement comme vous l'avez rappelé
confronté au fait de devoir voler une
voiture voilà il était avec plusieurs
personnes à bord il a vu le badaud
effectivement alors que ce n'est pas
très clair mais là c'était que la
première audience s'est visiblement
c'est un des passagers qui lui a dit
peut-être était-il mieux placé je ne
sais pas qui lui a dit bon vas-y tu des
gommes le sens si vous me passez
l'expression parce que sinon comme on
vole une voiture il faut pas il faut pas
que ça se sache mais ce n'était pas un
supérieur hiérarchique
parce que c'était lui le le sergent
voilà sans doute sous la pression le
stress un bon normalement le procès
devrait permettre d'élucider ces
circonstances mais effectivement c'est
pas du tout pas du tout un génocidaire
mais en tout cas ce procès évidemment
retient l'attention une telle affluence
de journalistes internationaux que
l'audience d'ailleurs a même dû être
ajournée pour désengorger le tribunal a
dit mam il ya un risque à vouloir en
faire un symbole peut-on rendre
sereinement la justice dans un tel
contexte oui alors juste je voulais
revenir sur la première question parce
que je l'exposerai que le terme génocide
est très complexe à utiliser
juridiquement mais on a quand même
maintenant des témoignages multiples
d'une armée indisciplinée et dont la
violence contre les civils est assez
stupéfiante supposé être une arme et
voilà on nous parle l'armée rouge on
parle de structures extérieures en fait
on voit des types qui ont 21 ans qui
volent des bagnoles qui descendent des
gens qui violent les filles qui rendent
dans les maisons qui picolent qui casse
tout ha donc il ya quand même une double
culture à la fois de la violence
gratuite
parce que les témoignages de viols par
exemple devant les faits devant les
familles devant les enfants et que ça et
des témoignages d'un discipline c'est à
dire c'est pas une armée
après bien sûr on dira qu'on irak les
américains qui sont supposés discipline
et on fait on fait des horreurs aussi à
ibb à bourgheim mais encore une fois ça
quand même montre un trend est une forme
de de détestation de ce que c'est que
ces tuque rênes de ce que ça représente
cette espèce de résistance auxquels on
s'attend pas à ça il ya eu des études
très intéressante sur la violence russe
dans les familles et comment elle
s'exporte en fait deux la famille vers
la police ou vers l'armée et comme
moribond je voulais juste pointer ce que
ce disque dit aussi cette affaire
finalement de l'état de l'armée rugby
oui ou alors de la détestation de ce
qu'on leur demande de faire oui c'est ça
aussi parce que visiblement il y en a
beaucoup qui sont là
d'ailleurs lui même et le jeune sergent
a dit qu'en fait il s'était engagé parce
qu'ils devaient financièrement aider sa
maman
a pas d'idéologie derrière pour défendre
la patrie russe et cinq ans le sale
boulot qu'on leur fait faire visiblement
plus on fait aussi par des témoignages
le début de la guerre il ne savait pas
exactement quand ils s'entraînaient le 2
mai de la frontière exactement où ils
allaient et c'était une invasion ils ont
tous découvert au fur et à mesure
visiblement on leur avait pas tout dit
quand la sérénité des débats nécessaires
pour rendre plus équitable deux mois et
demi après la commission du crime et je
des représailles en guerre on va pas
rentrer dans
dans l'excès inverse du juridisme et de
la sérénité des débats il moi moi je
suis même assez frappé que dans un pays
comme l'ukraine en guerre il ya une
structure d'état relativement
opérationnel parce qu'ils aient des
procureurs il ya des gens qui enquêtent
il ya des gens qui monte des dossiers il
ya des juges et des policiers aidés qui
sont soutenus d'ailleurs par des
professionnels des enquêteurs
professionnels qui sont venus d'europe
ou des états unis donc pour un pays qui
aient frappé de face je trouve que la
structure publique et est assez présente
et ce procès peut-être que c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs de le public
ukrainien je lisais aujourd'hui cet
après midi le public ukrainien et plus
pour des procès en ukraine que des
procès ces pays parce qu'ils veulent que
ça se règle chez eux
déterritorialisé envoya oui parce qu'au
fond c'est balance il sait leur histoire
donc mais c'est ça qui ajuste qui pose
un petit peu plus même quand même c'est
que d'abord les procès vont très vite
j'ai lu en général ce genre de procès ça
prend deux trois ans là en deux mois et
demi ça se tient donc ses diffusée en
direct sur internet
il ya aussi une volonté en guerre il ya
aussi est aussi un récit une volonté
politique exploitation et
l'instrumentalisation d'une forme
peut-être
l'évolution vont vont condamner tous les
types de staël à davos talent en disant
que des traits des nazis et que ça donc
serré ci-contre récit mais quand même le
fait d'avoir un témoignage direct sur
des occurrences direct de d'assassinats
de civils parce que là on n'est même pas
dans le cas de l'ambiguïté militaire
militaire on est sur des militaires qui
tuent des civils que la n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté alors que ça soit en deux
mois au lieu de deux ans que toutes les
garanties de procédures soient pas
forcément respecter la signalisation un
vol de voiture alors qu'ils détruisent
des immeubles par ailleurs ce qui semble
effectivement un peu curieux comme un
genre bien aux preuves de la discipline
c'est c'est très important dans les
dents les corps militaires qu'il ya une
forme de discipline d'engagement qui
fait qu'il ya des choses qu'on ne fait
pas le plus possible
on va voir justement ce que dit la
procureur général d'ukraine elle s'est
exprimé sur twitter à propos de ce
procès
par ce premier procès nous envoyons un
signal clair chaque auteur chaque
personne qui a ordonné ou aidé à
commettre des crimes en ukraine
n'échappera pas à sa responsabilité
il ya clairement un objectif
d'exemplarité et aussi le caractère
implacable de la justice est ce que le
système crée net armée pour bruno daroux
que je suis pas assez connaisseur
judy sein des phillies à un défi pour
n'importe quel système je dis c'est à
dire en plus dans une zone d'une période
de guerre la procureure elle même qui
vient d'être cité annonce qu'il ya déjà
onze mille enquêtes en cours donc
effectivement dans un pays en guerre
c'est absolument énorme il ya quand même
quelques inquiétudes notamment du côté
de la cpi du côté de certaines ong qui
disent qu'à pas d'observateurs
internationaux voyage de journalistes
internationaux qui étaient là c'est
diffusé mais qui disent quand même
attention justement que l'ukraine
respecte vraiment l'état de droit pour
qu'ils aient pas quand même une forme
malgré tout deux d'instrumentalisation à
vouloir aller trop vite et à vouloir
faire des exemples l'une des craintes en
ukraine c'est que cette justice soit
rendue mais que au final les condamnés
russie sont effectivement condamné
servent ensuite de mener des échanges de
prisonniers c'est que la justice ne soit
pas à l'épée ne soit pas exercer appuyé
mais le ensuite en temps de guerre c'est
une course est un concept abstrait ou
gras dans un an verra dans six mois on
verra dans neuf mois et on peut revenir
sur une décision du juge mais où on peut
lui donner un caractère des gens qui ont
la guerre pendant des mois ils font un
traité ils sortent de la guerre ils
trouveront des dérangements encore une
fois je pense que la valeur d'exemple
dans ce cas précis est dans ce qu'on
verra venir en espérant qu'ils aient pas
d'instrumentalisation comme vous le
dites
ça parle à une opinion intérieur ça
parle à une opinion internationale et on
n'est pas en train de parler d'un voleur
de bois est donc le tipi dit oui j'ai
tué j'ai tué bobin très bien parlons-en
ce qui est important aussi
la chose qui change toutes les données
c'est que c'est des zones qui ont été
libérés c'est plus des zones qui sont
occupés donc on a des témoignages on a
des cadavres on a des gens qui ont été
enterrés toute la zone de kiev a été
libéré toute la zone qui est près de la
frontière
près de kharkiv c'est ça est lié et plus
ou moins libéré donc les gens témoignent
les procureurs sont là les policiers
sont là 32,1 on n'est plus dans un
enquêteur
ja il ya une armée d'occupation quittent
qui bloque les deux sinon ça aurait eu
encore plus de force par exemple si
c'était des des soldats russes qui ont
commis par les exactions à bout de chat
voilà que vous avez été traduits en
justice j'imagine que là il y en a
bluffé les témoignages et des soldats
qui ont fait il ya qui ont repassé la
frontière pour éviter de se faire
rattraper ce qui prouve effectivement
tout cas là la crainte d'une forme de
justice le groupe français lafarge d'une
voix sa mise en examen confirmé dans la
sphère concernant sa cimenterie cyrielle
le site avait poursuivi son activité
alors même que la syrie elle s'enfonçait
dans la guerre lafarge est soupçonné
pour ce faire d'avoir versé à à l'époque
plusieurs millions d'euros à des groupes
terroristes dont l'organisation était
islamique des faits qui remontent à 2013
conséquence et bien lafarge est
poursuivi pour complicité de crimes
contre l'humanité et mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui ses ex-salariés syrien
en l'occurrence présent dans cette
cimenterie de dyala biya en zone de
guerre une affaire qui a connu plusieurs
rebondissements brunoy parce que c'est
vrai que ce sont des va et vient oui
parce qu'en fait il ya il ya deux types
d' accusations qui sont portées contre
lafarge personne morale ce qui est assez
nouveau je crois en droit français même
si après ce sont des responsables qui
doivent répondre de ce café lafarge en
syrie avec la complicité de vous l'avez
dit mise en danger de la vie d'autrui et
complicité de crime contre l'humanité
dont il ya eu un premier jugement d'une
première cour d'appel qui a écarté la
création de crimes contre l'humanité et
puis ensuite la cour de cassation a dit
pas non nous on estime que ça peut que
ça peut figurer comme chef d'accusation
donc à la cour d'appel d'avoir payé des
groupes terroristes en fait un de les
avoir alimenté en ressources voilà
absolument leur avoir acheté du pétrole
aussi
rue leurs commerces et même avec d'avoir
commercé avec eux jusqu'en septembre
2014 où les jihadistes ont pris la
cimenterie qui là s'est arrêtée donc
voilà on en est là et
lafarge annoncent aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont à nouveau se tourner vers la cour
de cassation alors là on entre un peu
dans le détail juridique technique parce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est la cour de
cassation peu une deuxième fois se
prononcer sur la recevabilité des
plaintes qu'elle l'a déjà fait une
première fois bon certains juristes se
disent que la première fois c'était
juste la chambre criminelle de la cour
de cassation s'est prononcée là ce
serait la coller une plénière vous
voulez de la cour de cassation et que
c'est possible quand ça se passe avant
les procès voilà c'est pas possible que
ça se passe après un procès mais j'ai
appris plein de choses et nous il ya vu
à fond ce soit c'est d'une affaire qui
pourrait créer un précédent parce
qu'elle a valeur d'exemple
il ya d'autres entreprises évidemment
présente en zone de guerre dans des
zones où l'on trouve effectivement des
minerais notamment où voilà d'uranium
qui peut servir aux scolaires c'est ce
qui est intéressant est tragique dans
cette histoire c'est le niveau de
responsabilité c'est à dire qui prend
des décisions de ce type si jamais elles
sont avérées
qui donne des ordres
qui les acceptent qui les exécutent pour
payer quand même des gens qui étaient en
guerre finalement avec la france qui
voulait monter des opérations d attaque
les attentats etc quand même c ca c'est
assez incroyable la deuxième chose c'est
ça remonte jusqu'aux est ce qu'il ya eu
un blanc seing bord je sais que ce monde
tout le monde de tout le monde se sente
s'intéresse à cette histoire parce qu
est ce que les politiques sont mêlées
mais moi je suis quand même stupéfait
par la capacité à l'autre du capitalisme
sauvage là c'est vraiment ça c'est on
prend une assurance on paye des dizaines
de millions pour faire tourner une usine
qu'on vient d'inaugurer au lieu de la
fermer c'est quand même au niveau de la
responsabilité individuelle et morale
comme on le disait cc c'est assez
impressionnant et derrière ça il ya une
affaire économique majeur parce que
comme la société a été rachetée par son
look son lit de phares par son
concurrent leader mondial et lisible
c'est une bombe atomique dans les
comptes d'holcim c'est à dire que ça
peut faire et aussi me dis qu'au moment
de la fusion n'était pas au courant il
n'était pas au courant
traîtrise donc il a au coeur de ses
comptes un truc atomique qui peut leur
sauter à la figure donc c'est vraiment
impressionnant les entreprises bosdarros
ne peuvent plus se cacher da finalement
l'ignorance du contexte politique en
plaidant que finance ça ça n'est pas
leur affaire meba wishful thinking on
aimerait bien ce soit comme ça mais
enfin mais si on regarde la même ce qui
se passe actuellement on sait que malgré
toutes les sanctions qui ont été votées
par exemple par l'union européenne
contre la russie certaines entreprises
dans certains pays continuent continue
malgré des sanctions alors qu'elles ne
devraient pas le faire à commercer avec
la russie donc oui dans un monde idéal
il faudrait que les entreprises
n'appliquent pas le principe business is
business il reste c'est pas nos affaires
mais on en n'est pas là il ya quand même
un changement de mentalité on l'a vu
chez beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont
quitté a pas plus tard que hier ou
avant-hier un mcdonald's qui quitte la
russie renault qui se sépare de dacia ça
montre quand même une évolution sensible
ce serait que le débat soit purement
morale et éthique dire pour renault la
russie c'est des centaines de millions
d'euros c'est une usine cédés
participation c'est du stock des
investissements pour mcdonald's c'est
des milliers de magasins donc c'est pas
uniquement
moralement éthiquement j'espère qu'ils
ont une réflexion mais quand il fait
quoi c'est le sait le name and shame la
peur de nu dégâts sur l'image non je
pense qu'il ya pour la plupart de ces
entreprises il ya aussi un impact
économique très violent et vous prenez
on n'en parle pas beaucoup en france en
ce moment mes gars sur les noms des sur
les comptes sur les comptes d entrain
difficile au fond ça effectivement un
impact sur leur compte ils scott ils
ferment et qui sortent il me le faut
quand même il parce que il espère
atténuer sortir en douce ou sortir mieux
et que cela ou balpa bleus née en france
de l'exposition des banques françaises
aux risques russe oui il ya aussi
l'apport d'une perte sèche plus tard si
la guerre dégénère ce que vous dites
voilà on restera là qu'il est d'accord
merci bruno daroux mercier galles n'est
souvent pas loin
vivable ici aussi l'intérêt de cette
émission les opinions convergent merci
et merci à vous de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal d'en parler
[Musique]